what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain every colossal titan in the
history of attack on titan
this shifter stands at 60 meters tall
and is the first one we ever saw in the
series
although at the time we didn't know it
was being controlled by a 12 year old
child
in terms of pure strength alone the only
intelligent titan that could beat this
thing is probably a full powered
founding titan
as the others don't come anywhere close
remember how back in season three when
reiner and zeke fought to decide what
they should do next
well there's a reason berto wasn't
involved in that battle because he could
have punted zeke all the way back to the
mali incontinence
in this video i'll be breaking down the
backstory of the colossal titans we know
as well as explaining its full powers
and other colossals throughout history
if you haven't already then be sure to
hit that sub button for more videos like
this
since this month i will also be doing a
video on every founding titan as well
okay so just before we get into the main
event i should briefly highlight the
difference between the colossal and the
wall titans because they do look
remarkably similar
whereas the former has existed in some
form for nearly 2000 years
the war titans have only been around for
a hundred years and their purpose was to
seal in the people of paradise
culprits created them using the founder
and he designed them with the colossal
titan in mind
hence their skinless design and nearly
identical physicality
despite that they are still roughly 10
meters shorter hence why berto was
comfortably able to see over the wall
like most pure titans in this series the
ones within the wall are unable to move
when there's no sunlight which is why
pasta dick was so desperate for that
hole to be covered
if light had touched it it's possible a
partial rumbling could have begun there
and then
but the power of the founder is the most
guaranteed way of making that happen
we saw in season 4 how woody tiger said
that the rumbling would eradicate all
life on the planet since nothing can
defeat an army of war titans
well except maybe an army of colossals
anyway let's get into the full backstory
of the first colossal on this list
then the protest will also be explaining
its full powers
bertolt hoover was an alien born in the
liberia internment zone where from a
young age he trained to become a warrior
for mali
while we've never physically seen his
parents we know from this exchange
between reiner's mother and annie's
father
that bertostad was a significant
influence on his life as a child
berto was incredibly skilled with a
rifle with the manga showing us this
scene where he was doing target practice
alongside other potential candidates
whereas ryan missed the target
completely
bertok repeatedly fired accurate shots
and this was the moment when mcgath
promoted him to warrior candidate status
in my opinion his good aim can be
partially attributed to his calm
demeanor
that usually kept him focused under
pressure unless annie was involved
compared to the other warriors bursal
rarely got overly angry or lost a sense
of who he was but the downside to his
personality was that he was quiet and
rarely took initiative for himself
reiner even called him out for this
before the battle of shiganshina saying
he was the strongest of them all
yet preferred to follow rather than take
charge after becoming a warrior
candidate
bursa was eventually selected to inherit
the colossal titan but just like reiner
he was unable to see the memories of his
predecessors
while some titan shifters lose control
the first time they transformed bursa
was noted to have mastered this power
immediately
which is a great thing because if you
lose control with this titan then it
could be game over for a lot of people
two years later he was one of the four
warriors selected to travel to parodies
to kidnap the founding titan
and the day he left for the mission was
the last time he saw his family
when they finally arrived at war maria
bertolt was skeptical if he really had
the strength to break through
but luckily the gates themselves are
made of bricks so it was an easy job
now in terms of its full powers this
shifter is more than simply a gigantic
titan
otherwise it never would have made it
this far we saw in season 2 how its slow
movement allowed the survey core to
easily maneuver around it
but bursa was able to survive due to a
discharge of hot steam
this steam emission is one of the main
selling points of the colossal as it
effectively acts as a barrier that
protects it from other living things
or indeed weapons like thunderspears
usually most titans emit steam when
they're either healing or in the process
of dying
but this shifter can burn its own muscle
mass to release steam when it wants and
turn up the heat if necessary
furthermore bertolt attacked wall rose
during the battle of trust and his titan
instantly disappeared in a split second
which is not something we've seen any
other shift to do
this vanishing act is likely linked to
steam emission in some way
due to how it burns up the colossal's
muscles on that occasion bettor used his
odm gear to escape after his titan
disappeared which is a contrast to what
happened at war maria where he was a
sitting duck waiting to be eaten
if you've ever wondered how he got stuck
in this situation it was because the
colossal can't do two consecutive
transformations so he wasn't able to
transform again to defend himself
so yeah if the dining fritz titan wanted
to eat bertolt it definitely could have
done so
moving over to this titan's most famous
ability besides its size the colossus
can generate a crazy explosion upon
transformation
while other shifters do pack a punch
when they're transforming the biggest
destruction was saved for the biggest
shifter
as we've seen now on multiple occasions
by releasing the full strength of the
explosion
berto wiped out a good chunk of
shigajina killing countless side
characters in the process
and also nearly hanji as well it's
important to realize that the user
chooses how much destruction they're
about to cause since there have been
occasions where the colossal might want
to minimize damage
or go for a more speedy approach in
terms of design
berto's colossal lacks any skin and its
muscle body is possibly the most iconic
among all the titans
all colossal titans also have stumpy
feet to support their size and this
scene in season 3 gave us a perspective
on just how tiny other shifters are when
compared to this giant
last thing to mention on bertott is that
he had a long standing crush on annie
and this was something that armin used
to try and manipulate him on two
separate occasions
other people like reiner were also aware
of his feelings towards her but annie
herself was never seen to acknowledge it
in any way
bertolt didn't get the chance to tell
her how he felt but his feelings would
live on through her successor who grew
attracted to annie even when she was in
a coma
armen inherited the colossal titan after
possibly the most polarizing selection
of all time
where he was chosen above commander
irwin usually when a titan is being
inherited
it's already been decided who's going to
get it otherwise it can lead to awkward
situations where families argue or just
threaten each other with swords
levi's decision to choose army was
controversial but whether it was him or
commander urban that was chosen
humanity was guaranteed to benefit in
some way by this point in the series
armin's genius mind had come up with
multiple different plans and helped to
uncover the identities of marley's
warriors earning the complete trust of
owen himself
when looking at both of their
backstories it's no coincidence that
each of them came from inquisitive
households that didn't simply believe
everything the government told them as
these environments fostered their
sometimes unorthodox ways of thinking
in armin's case his family was one of
the few on parodies to have evidence
that a world existed outside the walls
given that his grandfather's book
detailed the epic landscapes that
existed in foreign countries
material like this was totally illegal
and the royal government would often use
mps to kill people who show genuine
curiosity
during his childhood armin was an
outcast compared to the other kids in
shiganshina
and didn't have any friends until aaron
happened to approach him typically armen
would get beaten up by other children
yet he never fought back since he'd
rather talk things out and this was a
trait that followed him all the way into
adulthood
aaron on the other hand was of the
mindset that you need to fight back so
in time he and mikasa just ended up
fighting on army's behalf
a few years before marley attacked
parodies armin discovered his
grandfather's book about the outside
world
and showed it to aaron this moment is
what sparked both the desires to one day
see the ocean
but it also began aaron's hatred towards
the titans since he thought they were
responsible for keeping humanity trapped
in the walls
one interesting detail about that day is
that armin revealed his parents were
planning to visit the outside world
and later in the series it's implied
that they were murdered by military
police
mr and mrs arlet created their own hot
air balloon from scratch
but the mps eliminated them to maintain
the status quo
luckily for arma's grandfather his
material about the outside world wasn't
known to authorities so he was able to
join armin in escaping
after beltop broke the wall upon
arriving in wall roads as refugees
there just weren't enough resources to
feed everyone and a year later the
government took drastic action
rather than trying to find a reasonable
solution they essentially decided to
cull the population by sending refugees
on a fake mission to retake war maria
a quarter of a million people were sent
into titan territory to reclaim this
land
yet only 100 people returned alive
amid's grandfather was one of the poor
souls who died on that suicide mission
meaning the only people he had left were
aaron and mikasa
as a result he followed aaron's decision
to enlist in the military
and among this group of trainees who had
six of the nine titan shifters
as well as the secret ads to the throne
but you know army was pretty special too
during their time as trainees it was
clear the army was physically weaker
than average but academically he was top
of the class
that's why it was recommended that he
become a technician but ultimately he
chose to join the survey corps
this decision had two main benefits
number one it allowed him to stay with
his friends
and number two it also allowed him to
explore some of the outside world beyond
the walls
during his first battle in trust armin
was paralyzed in fear by the pure titans
and was unable to fight back when the
santa claus titan swallowed him whole
in normal circumstances that would have
been the end but aaron was able to grab
his friend at the last second and throw
him out single-handedly
besides being an amazing feat of
strength from aaron army could only
watch on as his childhood friend was
devoured
which was possibly the most baffling
moment of early attack on titan
as i mentioned earlier this battle
occurred after the colossal titan
breached the wall
and so it's crazy to think that armor
would inherit the power of the colossal
roughly four months later in terms of
how he then used this shifter
armin works with eren as one of the main
defenses for parodies
against mali's survey ships his main
feat of power in the anime so far
was when they went to mali and used the
full power of the colossal explosion to
obliterate the ports
when i saw those heavy warships flying
into the air that really put it into
perspective just how ludicrously strong
this titan is
now moving on to the other closer titans
for this part of the video i will be
going into major spoilers for attack on
titan
if you don't want to know stuff from the
second half of the final season then i
suggest you check out now because it
really does not get any more spoilery
than these spoilers
okay so in the penultimate chapter of
this series we got the surprise
appearance of another colossal titan
only this time there was a twist unlike
the colossals of the past this one was a
brand new version created by aaron
so that he could take on colossal armin
in their fistfights aaron's version was
distinctive from any other we've seen
mainly due to the fact it had a full
head of hair
and hardened fists this type of
hardening is not something i imagined
the colossal could do
but aaron put it to good use by blowing
a hole in arm and skull
if you're wondering how he was able to
create this titan in the first place
the power of the founder basically gives
a person free reign to do whatever they
want
just like how carl fritz created
millions of wall titans aaron simply
turned himself into a colossal
to have this final battle this encounter
was likely the first and only time
when two colossals fought in in combat
and i think we can all agree that aaron
was the winner before mikasa intervenes
to me it's quite ironic that both eren
and armin would one day become like this
since it was this exact shifter that
ruined their lives in the first place
throughout history there was only one
ancient version of this shifter that we
got to see
and that came in chapter 122. it pretty
much looks like bertott's version
because his ribs and neck are covered in
muscles which was not the case when it
came to aaron and armin
as always thank you guys for watching
this video on every class of titan and
don't forget to drop a like if you want
to see more
content like this until the next one
peace out